The mid-nineteenth century called it progress. They lit up the cities with gas, and for the
first time, the sun wasn't a tyrant. It was just another inconvenience. Charles Baudelaire saw it
clearly, though. That cold, clinical glow wasn't liberation. It was a new kind of shadow, one that
didn't just push back the dark, it rewrote the rules of night itself. And now, we've perfected
the art. We call it artificial light as a spiritual guide. Light isn't just illumination anymore.
It's a command, a directive to your body, whispered in wavelengths. Your zeitgeber, the external
metronome that once kept you in sync with the earth, has been replaced by something far more
efficient, something that never sleeps, something that keeps you in eternal biological noon.
The first step is the melatonin sunder. Melatonin is the hormone of surrender. It tells your body,
night is coming. Repair begins. But you don't want repair. You want the opposite. So you bathe in blue
light screens, glowing like false dawns, while your body still believes in dusk. Your brain gets the
message, daytime, stay awake. Your body gets the message, shutdown, sleep. And so you hover in that
limbo, a half-living thing, caught between what your eyes see and what your cells know. The instructions
are simple. First, the blue screen vigil. You dune scroll in the dark. The screen burns white hot
against the void, and your brain, desperate for contrast, obeys. Melatonin withers. Sleep inertia
becomes your middle name. You wake groggy, but not because of rest, because of betrayal. Then the
fluorescent workspace. No warmth, no softness. Just the sterile glow of cool white LEDs designed to mimic
nothing so much as the absence of life. Sunset? That's for people with destinations. You have a
screen, and the light is always the same cold, unyielding, the perfect companion for a mind that's
learned to distrust its own rhythms. Next, the blackout fallacy. You seal yourself off from the sun
during the day, as if daylight were a threat. Your body never gets the signal to start. It just sits.
And sits. Couch calcification sets in. Your kitchen, your body stops cooking. It stops living.
Finally, the intermittent flicker. A failing bulb. A screen that stutters. Your amygdala, that ancient
alarm system, never quite knows what to expect. Just enough panic to keep you on edge. Just enough
uncertainty to make sure you never relax. And what do you become? A human neon. Bright. Visible. Hollow.
You glow in the dark, but there's nothing inside. The sun is for those with places to go. The light
bulb is for those who've surrendered to the screen. Consider the 3 a.m. coffee. Blue light. Caffeine.
A perfect storm of chemical agitation. Your body, already adrift, now spins faster. The next day
arrives, and with it, the master class of the dead hour, a symphony of exhaustion disguised as
productivity. The sun was never the enemy. It was just the first thing they had to replace.
All together, and theirst of the dead hour, a symphony of exhaustion